i
[Música]
nueva ascendencia por un crimen racial
en estados unidos cadena perpetua fueron
condenados los tres hombres implicados
en la muerte del afroamericano about are
very los hechos ocurrieron en febrero de
2020 en georgia mientras el joven corría
por un barrio mayoritariamente blanco
cuando fue perseguido y asesinado por
dos sujetos mientras el otro grababa el
hecho tenemos reporte
se agudiza la situación en kazajistán la
comunidad internacional pide al
presidente casi joe mattock a efe que
respete los derechos humanos y que anule
su orden de disparar sin previo aviso a
los manifestantes el gobierno ahora
cuenta con el apoyo de rusia y china
para mitigar el estallido social
francia toma las riendas de la
presidencia rotatoria del consejo de la
unión europea el presidente de manuel
macrón recibió en parís a la presidenta
de la comisión europea úrsula von der
leyen y expresaron sus preocupaciones en
torno a la escalada de conflicto entre
rusia y ucrania e insistieron en la
necesidad de un proyecto de defensa
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz empezamos en eeuu
donde fueron condenados a cadena
perpetua tres hombres blancos
involucrados en la muerte del
afroamericano akm out are very de 25
años en febrero de 2020 el juez calificó
de escalofriante el hecho que ocurrió
cerca de la comunidad de brands week en
el estado de georgia cuando harvey
corría por el vecindario de los
atacantes nuestro corresponsal en
washington cristóbal vázquez con los
detalles del caso travis buck michelle
su padre y greg magnitud y williams ryan
fueron sentenciados a cadena perpetua
por haber perseguido y asesinado ahmad
are very un ciudadano afroamericano de
25 años que salió a trotar en febrero
del 2020 por un barrio de población
predominantemente blanca en el estado
sureño de georgia y no se detuvo cuando
estos ciudadanos blancos lo empezaron a
seguir
william bryant será el único de los tres
que podrá aplicar a casa por cárcel u
otros beneficios más adelante sin
embargo la defensa apelará la sentencia
argumentando que los autores del crimen
disparar en defensa propia y por
sospecha de robo de harvard y quien
según ellos estaba rondando una casa
vecina el caso ha generado muchas
críticas al sistema judicial en eeuu
porque a pesar de las denuncias los
fiscales sólo abrieron una investigación
cuando el vídeo del asesinato se hizo
viral en redes sociales en mayo del 2020
al respecto la madre dijo que estaba
convencida de que hoy iba a salir
victoriosa de la corte y que los
criminales tenían que afrontar ahora las
consecuencias de sus actos y se agudiza
la situación en kazajistán después de
las masivas y violentas protestas contra
el alza del precio del combustible que
además han sido reprimidas por las
fuerzas de seguridad ahora el presidente
casi lo mató kfor de no disparar a matar
sin previo aviso a los manifestantes
organizaciones internacionales han hecho
un llamado a retirar la orden y a
respetar los derechos humanos de acuerdo
con el ministerio del interior- 26
civiles y 18 uniformados han muerto
durante las manifestaciones
ahora la ex república soviética no sólo
cuenta con el apoyo de rusia sino
también de china lo que ha generado
críticas de occidente para discutir este
tema saludamos en la capital argentina
andrés servín doctor en ciencias
políticas y analista internacional y
presidente del think tank regional tries
bienvenido a france 24 señor servín esta
orden tan radical y apresurada del
presidente kazajo podría reflejar que el
mandatario prevé que la situación se le
puede salir de las manos
pero es altamente probable que tenga
algún grado de inseguridad con respecto
a la capacidad de controlar una
situación que se ha desbordado en un
país que ha tenido prácticamente tres
décadas de estabilidad pero que ha
tenido una transmisión de poder
importante entre el anterior presidente
durante prácticamente tres décadas
nazarbáev los resultandos álvarez y el
actual toca es y que por además tiene
una situación de tensión entre ellos y
de alguna manera cuando toca el fue
asumido la presidencia del consejo de
seguridad para controlar la situación ha
desplazado fuertemente a nursultán
nazarbáev esto beneficia la calidad no
digo que esto beneficia en cierto modo
también a pesar de que la oportunidad no
es propicia a un mayor control de rusia
en uno de los estados más importantes de
asia central y fundamental en lo que es
la organización de la unión económica
eurasiática por ahora dodd el tratado de
seguridad colectiva en esa área del asia
central ahora hemos visto el apoyo del
gobierno kazajo de grandes potencias y
además vecinos como rusia y china porque
son importantes estas protestas para la
región
pero las protestas pueden devenir en una
situación que es altamente preocupante
particularmente para rusia que no quiere
ver otra revolución de colores y una
protesta de la sociedad civil que
eventualmente pueda desestabilizar un
gobierno que favorable a sus intereses y
al mantenimiento de su área de
influencia en un momento donde además
existe este foco de tensión en ucrania
que afecta y amenaza la capacidad de
rusia de influir señor andrés servín
doctor en ciencias políticas muchas
gracias por acompañarnos aquí en
france24 y a partir de hoy y durante los
siguientes seis meses francia tomará las
riendas de la presidencia rotativa del
consejo de la unión europea la
inauguración oficial de este periodo
tuvo lugar en parís y contó con la
visita de la presidenta de la comisión
europea úrsula von der leyen ambos
líderes expusieron sus preocupaciones
por la atención entre rusia y ucrania y
han reafirmado su compromiso de reforzar
una política de defensa común para el
bloque
con problemas en aumento en la frontera
oriental de la unión europea el espinoso
tema de una política de defensa común
está de vuelta en la agenda en meses
recientes la movilización de tropas
rusas a la frontera con ucrania ha
disparado las tensiones pero mientras
bruselas cree que debería jugar un rol
central en las negociaciones moscú
parece pensar diferente
acaso putin está pasando por alto a la
unión europea si skill sweet reps y eso
es lo que él desea porque no tiene
consideración por la unión europea y
está completamente determinado a tratar
de arruinar la unidad de europea que se
está consolidando
rusia parece haber hecho un desaire al
bloque de los 27 para los diálogos al
preferir una serie de reuniones cara a
cara con eeuu y la otan para la próxima
semana por años las divisiones internas
sobre el papel de la defensa han
frustrado los intentos europeos de
construir una política común de defensa
pero ahora los líderes dicen que la
agresión rusa le ha dado al bloque el
ímpetu que necesita para seguir adelante
con un proyecto de defensa
necesitamos tener un diálogo con rusia
que dada su historia y geografía será
clave para el diseño de la arquitectura
europea de seguridad que debemos
construir y creo que está llegando la
hora de que el proyecto de defensa
europea se ponga en marcha así que
repito no habrá solución a menos que
involucre a europa
que sentar a la mesa a los estados
miembros de la unión europea cada uno
con lenguajes e historias distintas para
hablar de una política de defensa común
no es tarea fácil pero los proponentes
de la idea argumentan que es la única
manera de asegurar que europa sigue
haciendo soberana en un mundo
rápidamente cambiante
el tenista serbio novak djokovic
agradeció el respaldo de sus seguidores
luego de haber sido detenido por las
autoridades australianas tras ingresar
al país al parecer sin estar vacunado el
caso del número 1 del mundo ha generado
un incidente diplomático entre australia
y el país balcánico
mensajes de simpatía desde los rincones
menos esperados el tenista serbio novak
djokovic ha recibido el apoyo de su
hinchada desde las calles de belgrado
hasta la habitación contigua en
melbourne donde se encuentra detenido
por negarse a presentar un certificado
de vacunación
aceves lo siento mucho por él porque no
le deseo la detención australiana a
nadie australian
nobody sanma
old lions
creo que un contexto político de por
medio así que realmente le deseo suerte
y le deseo libertad lo mismo para
nosotros
wisin
el campeón del abierto de australia 2021
que desconoce si podrá defender su
título este año se como un tiempo para
agradecer en redes sociales
gracias a las personas de todo el mundo
por su apoyo continuo puedo sentirlo y
se los agradezco mucho australia que
registra 762 1504 contagios acumulados
de kobe 19 según el conteo de la
universidad johns hopkins exige un
esquema de vacunación completo para los
participantes del torneo o en su defecto
una exención médica como anunció haber
recibido el propio jugador semanas atrás
sin embargo las autoridades revocaron el
visado de djokovic por supuestas
irregularidades con la extensión
generando incomodidad entre serbia y
australia
el señor djokovic no está cautivo en
australia es libre de irse en cualquier
momento que lo desee la fuerza
fronteriza lo facilitará
este 7 de enero la jugadora checa renata
voracova fue enviada al mismo hotel para
migrantes detenidos en melbourne luego
de conocer sobre la cancelación de su
visa mientras el serbio espera una
decisión de la justicia australiana
sobre su participación en el torneo
recibió la buena nueva de que será
bienvenido en el roland garros que se
realizará en parís en mayo gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]